in this video I'm going to show you how
to use a computer a piece of paper a
pencil a pencil sharpener if you want to
listen while reading and mark
phonetically the text end I'm going to
use a text in English it goes 31st is a
night for some bright children so this
is the first sentence where I've marked
the intonation going up October 31st I'm
introducing the subject then I'm going
up for fun because I haven't finished
yet so my tone goes up and then the
sentence falls on fright because I have
concluded saying the sentence itself so
I just stopped the recording there was
really easy to do with my left end and
then I with my right hand I'm just
marking the text phonetically with the
spend so very easy and straightforward
to do let's get let's continue ages
Austria so here pages dress up in
costumes eventually I can even go down
and come back for example because I can
start again and listen again to the
first sentence of those thirty first and
fright children of all ages throw
something at hofstra the wrong
little girls because of this fairies
princesses ballerinas and the like to
stop here and the like going down as you
can see here you have the intonation
patterns going up going up coming up
this is a list for example here fairies
princesses ballerinas and the like going
back a little bit there are little girls
obviously here the tone is going up
because I haven't finished yet so this
is a relative clause there are little
girls who dress up and then you continue
I stopped the sentence and then I'm
gonna deal with the following one
these men and it's prettier so that's
exactly the same pattern here there are
little boys there's a relative clause oh
I'm going to continue and that's the
reason why the tone goes up and then you
have a list of elements firefighters
policemen and superheroes so you have
the tone going up on firefighters
policemen and then the tone falling down
on the stressed syllable of the last
element of the of the entire list let's
keep going on as you can see it's really
clear again you also have the children
going up relative clause and then you
have furry animals the tone is going up
because I haven't finished or ghoulish
ghosts you have the the accents the tone
falling down on the last element we so
here one thing is certain it's like a
statement so the accent is falling down
not necessarily all the sentence is not
necessarily the the main stress or the
accent following falls on the last
element of the sentence there's a comma
here not mat no matter what costume you
choose this is distressed element the
most important one there is sure to be a
lot of candy and chocolate going up here
involved in Halloween accent falling on
Halloween trick-or-treating as a child
and using a pillowcase as my goody bag
this ensured that I would have plenty of
room
for the ridiculous amounts of chocolate
that I collected
I remember having many stomachaches in
the week that followed Halloween I
probably had enough candy to last a
month but I ate it all within a few
within a few days some parents take
their children candy and will only allow
them a certain amount each day however
my mom wanted to get it over with
she thought it was better to let me eat
it all at once didn't have to listen to
me whine about candy for a whole month
you might also have the impression that
Halloween is just for kids but you would
be wrong
many adults take part in the festivities
as well for example there are many
parties that take place all over the
city
most people press up in costumes and
often there are prizes given for the
best ones some adults spend months and a
lot of money coming up with unique and
elaborate costumes I believe that some
adults have more fun on Halloween the
most children do furthermore many of
dolls and teenagers like to set off
fireworks and firecrackers there are
often wonderful fireworks displays and
parts and schools usually they are put
on firefighters to make sure that nobody
gets hurt October 31st is generally not
a peaceful night so if you think you
will be going to bed early you had
better think again often there are
teenagers setting off firecrackers until
only hours of them
so here you have it this was a very
practical straightforward simple and
short training to get the phonetic
patterns of the English have used
English here but you can use it for
Spanish or any other language you want
it really does make a difference
if you start doing this from the very
beginning
[Music]